on connaît la chlorophylle dans les
chewing-gums un peu moins pour les
crèmes de beauté c'est pourtant le pari
qu'on fait les deux tours enjaux en
lançant il y a 4 ans leur entreprise de
cosmétique ce pigment qui donne leur
couleur verte au végétaux aurait de
nombreux bienfaits le laboratoire
chambréien vient d'ailleurs d'être
retenu dans le programme France 2030 qui
soutient les startups Aurélie Renaud
dans cette sphère en verre peut-être
l'avenir de la cosmétique et de la
pharmacologie une huile à base de
chlorophylle capable de protéger les
molécules les plus fragiles voilà ce que
vend le laboratoire érigère c'est Eric
Buchy sont directeur général qui a mis
au point le procédé lors de ses
recherches à la Faculté de Pharmacie de
Tours grâce à la chlorophylle on peut
concentrer beaucoup plus nos actifs à
l'intérieur de nos petites capsules on
les protège beaucoup mieux que les
autres technologies et elles sont plus
stables lorsqu'on les incorpore dans nos
produits finis lancé en 2019 et rigère
est loin de la start-up balbutiante
l'entreprise propose déjà aux
industriels du secteur une dizaine de
formules à base de chlorophylle
comprenant par exemple du CBD et de la
vitamine A
l'entreprise chambresienne poursuit en
parallèle ses recherches pour les
antibiotiques afin de les rendre plus
efficaces face aux bactéries résistantes
elle a pour cela reçu de l'État et de la
région une subvention de 500.000 euros
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030